the Independent Spirit Awards are sort
of the Indy Oscars they honor films here
that are a little bit more adventuresome
a little bit different a little more
experimental sometimes cheaper sometimes
better than the movies that are honored
at the Academy Awards and the people
together under this tent are the key
players in the independent film movement
in years past they've honored films here
like pulp fiction leaving Las Vegas
Fargo this year some of the nominees
include gods and monsters affliction
velvet goldmine Queen Latifah is going
to be the mistress of ceremonies we're
gonna see a lot of the top players
directors stars writers composers and
distributors of independent films so
welcome once again to the Independent
Spirit Awards Queen Latifah
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
like that hip-hop music welcome to the
Independent Spirit Awards live right
here on the independent film channel it
is the show that honors the best
independent films of 1998 now I'm kind
of new here so forgive me if I have to
ask an obvious question what the hell
does independent me hmm I take Good Will
Hunting now is that independent because
it was Miramax or is it mainstream
because it made a shitload of money you
feel me
and what about Armageddon that was a
number-one film last year what did it
had been a slacking Billy Bob five
minutes and what about the Bride of
Chucky
now that was made by an independent
studio and had Jennifer Tilly in it but
no nominations I mean what gives and
what about me and my mainstream because
I start in a sitcom or am i independent
because I started a fine line feature I
know what all the cliches about
independent film are you're an
independent filmmaker if your apartment
is just set your credit limit is your
budget your mom is your caterer your
sister's your best boy and Magic Hour is
anytime the camera is working
unless of course your film is being
financed by Miramax with a 20 million
dollar budget or you're an independent
filmmaker when only you and a close
circle of friends actually understand
your movie or you're an independent
filmmaker the moment you cast Steve
Buscemi let's see the cliches don't
quite get to the heart of the matter for
me for me independent cinema is like
pornography you know it when you see it
you know it's independent when the
filmmakers have some brains and expects
you to have the same - you know it's
independent when the women do something
besides fill out a bathing suit that's
right
you know it's independent when you see a
world you've never seen meet people you
never knew existed think of thought
you've never had before
you know it's independent when you can't
get it out of your head and that's what
it's about to me and we're gonna
celebrate something that's right
that's right
and we are going to celebrate some fine
independent films here today over 35 of
them in fact so let's get on with the
honors here to present the Award for
Best Debut performance is a former
winner of the award with her is an actor
who I think appears in every independent
film that has ever been made
please welcome Heather Monterey's oh and
Eric Stoltz
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
we're here to present the award for the
best debut performance and the nominees
are
Evan Adams for smoke signals Anthony
Roth Costanzo for soldiers daughter
never cries Andrea heart for Miss Monday
Sonia sown for Slam
and saw Williams for slam
and the spirit where goes to Indians
ain't supposed to smile like that gets
stoic he doesn't look like he just came
back from killing a buffalo but our
tribe never hunted Buffalo we were
fishermen
[Music]
[Music]
I'm completely flabbergasted I live up
in the woolly north of Canada and and so
this is all very new to me and I have
many people to thank because any
performance doesn't arrive of course as
you know on its own so I stand up here
with lots of people I'd like to thank
first of all my family my mom and dad
who taught me a lot about my home and
prepared me to play Thomas I would like
to thank my agent I'd like to thank
Miramax the boys at shadow catcher my
director Chris who babysat me through a
really difficult and wonderful shoot -
especially Sherman Alexie whose poetry I
got to get up and do every day and I
just had to remember the line says his
work did everything for me
My partner Dakota and all my friends
back in med school in Calgary thank you
very much
all right one down and 14 to go but it's
moving and we all keep it moving next up
is Best first screenplay and Best first
feature he nervous aren't you here to
present these awards is an actress who
will soon be seen in the film adaptation
of Kurt Vonnegut juniors breakfast of
champions with her is an actor who will
soon appear in the debtor's which he
produced with his wife Abby while she
directed please welcome
Vicky Lewis and Randy intoxication Queen
well we got a bad live a little bit
before the property comes on yeah what
is that that clear thing
Oh Vickie Lewis ad-lib okay good there
we go the nominees for Best first
screenplay are darren aronofsky for pi
Sherman Alexie for smoke signals
Lisa Cholodenko for hi art
[Applause]
tamra Jenkins for the slums of Beverly
go
and Matthew Weiss for Niagara Niagara
and the Spirit Award goes to Darren
Aronofsky for hi I'm careful with your
trash
you gave this faulty information oh you
dangled the carrot the right picks but
then you only gave us part of the code
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you very much whoo I got it I got
to thank well it's totally not my
screenplay it was a collaboration from
the beginning when when we decided make
an independent film I thought the best
thing to do was get partners because I
knew I couldn't do it by myself
so I got my roommate to be the producer
and a coach story by and my best friend
from college Sean galette to be my star
and Coast story by so the three of us
spent eight months collaborating it
picking all of our friends Minds from
Brooklyn and from everywhere we knew to
try and get as cool ideas on the paper
as possible so thank you very much and
we're shooting in four weeks this the PI
posse is back in action and this this
really means a lot to us and it'll help
thank you
yeah the before we get to the next award
Randy and I would like to do something a
little unusual you at home may not know
this at home but the Independent Spirit
Awards is a fundraiser for the IFP West
that's correct and the problem is it's
just not bringing in enough money on its
own so the IFP West has decided to
explore the field of film merchandising
by introducing a line of independent
film ice-creams it's a great idea
because you know I love ice cream yeah
well who doesn't love a big warm piece
of apple pie with a big hunk and look
here's that ah great here we go um I
don't know let me look and see oh I love
this one it's called what's right in
front of me
spanking the chunky monkey
that sounds good yeah absolutely and
here we have oh this is inspired by the
film Pulp Fiction it's called banana
Royale with cheese that's good oh this
one is uh this one here is called
chasing amy crunch evidently it starts
out being one flavor and then it
switches to another flavor and then it
goes back to being the flavor it was to
begin with chasing amy crunch sir that's
called like water for chocolate chip and
what is that it's Slingblade swirl and
it's a mustard flavor ice cream with
chunks of real biscuit real biscuit
vicki real biscuit randy and now we come
to a few for the more adventurous palate
this one is called happiness chunk it's
got little chunks of hershey in it yeah
you too much of it you go to prison yes
all right
are you or are you won't get distributed
no right
this one is simply called poison this is
simple and now we come to our last
independent film ice cream thank you I
don't quite get this one but it's called
the end of pink flamingos just happen
atmosphere I wonder whether groaning mmm
that's good it's cool well thank god
that's it for the commercial okay and
back to the awards we go unless sorry no
all right okay the next category is best
first feature and the nominees are
buffalo 66 directed
directed by vincent gallo and produced
by chris handling so we got a little
situation here I can't drive these kind
of cars would you like to know why I
can't drive this kind of car I'll tell
you why I'm used to luxury cars have you
ever heard of a luxury car you know what
luxury means have you ever heard of
Cadillac high art directed by Lisa
Cholodenko produced by Dali Hong gente
I don't want to do that with you all the
time
okay I mean I don't want that to be our
only connection the opposite of sex
directed by Don Roose produced by David
Kirkpatrick and Michael batsman we
didn't mean to hurt anyone you're gay
you jerk he just never met the right
woman yeah one with a dick it's not a
cut for your information I'm bisexual
please I went to a Bar Mitzvah once that
doesn't make me Jewish PI directed by
Erin Aronofsky produced by Eric Watson
maybe that pattern is like the pattern
in the stock market the Torah there's
two six the Nanami this is insanity max
well maybe it's genius
the slums of Beverly Hills directed by
Tamra Jenkins produced by Michael Nozick
and Stan will douse key what's that on
your face bad labor alone it's for her
mustache oh my god our sister is on
Aphrodite and the Independent Spirit
Award goes to the opposite of sex
directed by John Roos produced by David
Kirkpatrick and Michael batsman
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
this is such a great pleasure and honor
and we wouldn't really be here except
for Don ruses really brilliant script
and and his terrific direction we all
feel a little old here being first
feature nominees but I first of all want
to thank Tim he'll fit and Cox
broadcasting for financing the picture
and also for to Sony classics Michael
Barker and Tom Barnard and Dylan liner
for really putting it out there in the
marketplace and to the guys at Columbia
TriStar particularly Clint Culpepper and
Peter slaw so for picking up the movie
for us and Ben Feingold and hi thanks a
lot I really appreciate this award I
still haven't gotten over the goody bag
which is really wonderful so thank you
very much I want to thank David
Kirkpatrick for producing this movie and
Michael bessman for producing this movie
and and Keith samples for saying yes you
can have all the money you want to make
the movie then he had to resign and and
he really did me a great favor and and i
truly appreciate that and you know I
want to thank Steve Ravenel and Jaime
Mandelbaum who've been my team and who
really helped me but most of all I want
to thank the actors in my movie who who
made it just so easy for me I had never
directed anybody before and so they kind
of directed themselves and they did a
great job and I'm very grateful to
Christina and Lisa and Martin and Johnny
Galecki and Wow loved it
and my cinematographer is here who Berta
Janoski I really need to thank him
because I don't know from my line and
all that stuff and most of all I want to
thank damn butinsky
thanks a lot I just want to thank you
for recognizing this movie and for
working with Don Roose thank you
sunglasses ice cream look like munchies
than me but only those are you in a no
and get that see you know it's like soon
some young but those of you who don't
know the spirit award ceremony and ice
cream sales aren't the only thing that
the IFP West does every year
among the many programs the IFP West has
created is project involved which
provides 60 young people from
underrepresented communities with
filmmaking Mentors
and that's in addition to the library
seminars screenings and other programs
at the eiope West runs all year long
please show some love but one of the
people who make it all possible the
executive director of the IFP West dawn
Hudson
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
good afternoon it's good to see old and
new friends in this room today
welcome back Tom Barnard Michael Barker
Bingham ray
Harvey Weinstein all members of what
John Pearson calls the permanent
government of independent film it's also
good to see new faces here today artisan
banner Lionsgate shooting gallery and I
never thought I'd hear myself saying
this touchstone welcome to your first
Spirit Award ceremony and
congratulations it's been an extremely
to all of you thank you it's been an
extremely strong year for independent
film as we've just seen with those Best
first feature nominees we have a lot of
very independent films here today in
fact one of our best feature nominees
Clair Dolan is so independent that you
can only see it if you live in France so
thanks to everyone involved with the
Spirit Awards especially our producer
Diana's on story and her staff Holly
Wofford Stacey Willman and James Gordon
finally I would like to thank our
sponsors for the generous support first
thanks to our two principal sponsors
from Nevada watch Scott Woodward and
Lybia Murata and thank you from the runs
of Puerto Rico Maria Pico and Fernando
Martinez and thanks of course to our
three premier sponsors from
Entertainment Weekly Fred Nelson and
Kathleen Moore and from the independent
film channel my dear friends Jonathan
searing Kathleen door and Ed Carroll and
Thank You Polo Ralph Lauren for your
premier sponsorship and for the second
year of sponsoring the producers award
thank you all and for that award I'd
like to introduce the presenter she's a
nominee for Best Supporting female in
her role the opposite of sex so please
welcome the beautiful
very talented Lisa Kudrow
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hello oh this is probably so
inappropriate but congratulations Don
David and Michael is okay now imagine a
world without producers don't smile it's
not a joke
we're here to honor them I mean do you
want to do it go ahead we are actually
about to honor some hard-working
independent producers who don't fit the
usual stereotype that's why they're
being honored these are and I don't
dislike producers either it just sounds
like I do because of the bits that were
written but these these are tenacious
creative producers who managed with
limited resources to tell the kinds of
stories that we don't get from
mainstream movies and they're funded now
by Ralph Lauren the producers I read
that all the way wrong
the producers award comes with an
unrestricted grant of $20,000 so the
finalists for the second annual Ralph
Lauren producers award are Margot
bridger producer of arresting Geena and
the Delta
Gil Holland producer of hurricane
streets and spring forward
Andrea Sperling producer of nowhere and
dune generation
and Susan Stover
the sticky fingers of time and high art
[Applause]
alright this year's Ralph Lauren
producers award goes to
Susan Stover
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
well this is very thrilling and exciting
and and we saw like actresses dude
anyway it's been a great last five years
it's been an incredible time in my life
and I hope the next five are just as
exciting I must immediately pass all
credit on to the very talented directors
I've had a privilege to work with
starting with Kelly Reichert who
convinced me to leave the law more ways
than one actually and start making films
Larry Fessenden Rachel Reichman Bill
Oliver Greg sacks Pat stetner Hilary
broker and of course extraordinary Lisa
Cholodenko I also want to recognize my
my collaboration with Jeff levy hinty
and dolly Hall on high art that was an
amazing experience certainly appear
highlight for me would also like to give
a special thanks to Ted Hope who I feel
has always been the invisible hand
that's pushed me along as well as
Michelle Sattar and the Sundance
Institute
another special salute to my fellow
nominees Gil Andreea and Margot thank
you for your friendly and healthy
competition and of course big thanks to
the IFP and Ralph Lauren for your
generous sponsorship and appreciate it
very much
and finally for their unwavering support
and belief in me my I think my family in
Texas my friends in New York and my very
dear Jojo thank you
I see you here to present the Spirit
Award for Best Screenplay and Best
Supporting male is an actress who
actually has one of those other awards
for her role in my cousin Vinnie and her
co-presenter won last year Spirit Award
for Best Supporting male and will appear
in Kevin Smith's upcoming film Dogma but
dog must be from New York
please welcome Marisa Tomei and Jason
Lee
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I think we've all heard this phrase film
is a collaborative art and nobody knows
this better than the screenwriter in
fact one of this year's screenwriting
nominees David Mamet notes that
screenwriters often hear that phrase
this way film is a collaborative art
bend-over despite the difficult
positions in which screenwriters often
find themselves some still manage to get
an original vision on to the screen and
we honor five of those writers today the
nominees for Best Screenplay are Bill
Condon for gods and monsters
David Mamet for the Spanish prisoner
[Music]
great military for blind faith
don roose for the opposite of sex
Paul Schrader for affliction
ward goes to Don Roose for the opposite
of sex
[Music]
Dell's kind of cute isn't he two bodies
a fairy right that's not how I would put
it well
then too bad he's however you'd put it
[Music]
thank you very very much I wrote this
I'm trying to think of the people who
helped me write it and I can only think
of Bill Gates and Microsoft Word so I
thank him but I I really appreciate it
and the only reason that you saw this
screenplay is because Tom Barker and
Michael Bernard Oh Tom Barnard and
Michael Barker let you see the
screenplay and so did David Kirkpatrick
who actually had final cut on the movie
and deferred to me and and that's why my
script was heard and seen by by you and
I can't thank them enough and I really
appreciate this and thank you very much
okay the next category is Best
Supporting male the nominees are James
Coburn for affliction
Charles s Dutton for blind faith
dairy farmer for smoke signals
Philip Seymour Hoffman for happiness
and Bill Murray for Rushmore
and the spirit award goes to Bill Murray
for Russia butcher I am his friend oh
yeah friends like you who needs friends
Bill Murray
couldn't be here but he asked me to
deliver this speech so this is what he
said it's really nice of you to give me
this award but I felt that if I came to
the Independent Spirit Awards it would
send the wrong message to the Academy of
Motion Picture
[Applause]
Who I am still courting desperately
desperately courting but I couldn't be
more proud of the IFP for giving this
award to a motion picture a superstar
like myself it shows a lot of
Independence and a lot of spirits thank
you
[Music]
and I go leaving the garbage around
again okay take one of these home all
right Jill break out your vomit bags
because our keynote speaker this
afternoon is John Waters that's right
and here to introduce them is an actress
who has been a friend and colleague of
mr. waters since the vine ate his very
first turn
she's a trash cinema legend of veteran
independent film actress and currently
an advice columnist for glue magazine
please welcome make stove
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
when I first met John Waters in the
summer of 1966 he was this tall skinny
guy with his long stringy hair and a
pair of yellow aviator sunglasses that
he never took off there was nothing the
matter with his eyes it was just that
even then he knew the value of a
signature look
he was opinionated and supremely
self-assured the absolutely most
definite person I've ever known and I I
was naive little 18 year old little
Nancy stole and the most definite thing
about me was that I was craving
adventure so when John asked me to be
part of his movie I jumped at the chance
and it was the best yes answer I ever
gave in my life I got a great great
glamorous new name a new wonderful
circle of friends and although I didn't
know it at the time a chance to be part
of cinematic history or infamy depending
on your point of view now in those days
we didn't make independent features we
made underground movies and our working
conditions were extremely primitive we
didn't have luxuries like craft services
and the closest thing we ever got to a
trailer was the one I burned down in
pink flamingos John was practically a
one-man production company he had
Vincent Pirani Oh to design his sets and
Van Smith to do the hair and makeup
designs and the Wardrobe but he pretty
much did everything else on his own he
wrote the scripts he directed the film's
he produced the film's and he added to
the films and even though he had an
absolutely marvelous troupe of actors to
work with I secretly believed that their
if there had been any way for him to
play all the parts he would have done
that too he used to stand behind the
camera and mouth our dialogue as we were
working just to make sure we didn't
leave anything out
now I made sure that I never forgot my
lines if anybody was gonna blow a take
it was not going to be me because back
in those days we didn't work with pickup
shots or cutaway shots we work
exclusively in masters which meant that
if a line got blown at the end of a
scene we had to start all the way over
from the
and when it came time to show a film
John knew how to promote it as well
he used to gather us all together when
we go out wild posting we'd put flyers
on car windshields and hang posters and
phone booths and laundromats and it
worked
we always had a really good audience and
we loved it every minute of it
primitive conditions are not making
movies was what made our lives good now
a lot has changed since those days John
still lives in the East he still writes
and directs his movies I live out here
but now we make independent features and
we work with producers and line
producers and caterers and DPS and ADEs
and all the rest of the people that go
with it and it makes it a lot easier for
the actors but I have to admit I still
sometimes really miss the old days I
certainly miss a lot of the people I
miss Devine Edith Massey David Locker II
and cookie Muller and I sometimes really
really miss the crazy Kamikaze things we
had to do to get a film made but I still
love making movies now I'm very proud of
the 11 films that I have worked on with
John Waters he's given me some amazing
roles to play
Connie marble in pink flamingos taffy
Davenport in female trouble Dottie
Hinkle and serial mom they've been
really really good times
now I'm also very very proud of a 33
year friendship John Waters is an
amazing amazing man he is living proof
that no matter how outrageous you are if
you do something long enough and do it
well enough you can eventually achieve
respectability ladies and gentlemen John
Waters
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
like you
you make me feel like Aaron Alan I'd
like to say to the IFP membership for me
just not being nominated this year was
enough really what I wanted to do was
come out tonight and sing all five Oscar
songs for you and make direct eye
contact with every person in this
audience - you're squirming in your seat
ready to rush home and watch Kevin
Costner and the postman in slow motion
but since I'm more of a life-affirming
kind of guy these days I guess I'll talk
about my first bad cinematic influence
everybody needs a bad director to look
up to and thankfully I've been that for
a generation who wonderfully respects
their filth elders you know when I when
we started in the old days I mean my
idol was really William Castle that's
who I wanted to be when he was the king
of the gimmicks when I was a child I
prayed to William Castle I wanted to sit
on his lap at Christmas and he did great
things he'd go to his premieres and jump
out of a coffin he made you in sign
insurance policies in case you died of
fright he had buzzers going off under
the sea skeletons going over the
audience and I wanted to do this you
know but later I was insulted when
someone actually had a dust - John John
Waters show and the gimmick was you got
in free but you had to pay to get a help
but certainly you know we it's hard to
sell independent films I think we could
take William castles example and use it
for all five nominated films here today
I think affliction you could sell
two-for-one tickets bring an alcoholic
relative and he gets him free
think gods and monsters you have a
raffle and whoever wins gets to pick the
cutest uh sure to go home well if you
put in newly-installed handicap ramps in
your theater and I know their expense if
you have a velvet goldmine fashion show
really and the last person standing in
the platform's gets a year-long pass
Claire Dolan you show it in poorer
neighborhoods and jack up the prices of
the concession stand and then lend
patrons money to be able to buy their
favorite snacks and for James ivory my
soul brother in the extreme tastes
racket at the other end
a soldier's daughter never cry I think
that when you have Merchant Ivory
look-alike contest in the lobby
you know mink was right independent was
too highfalutin a word for us when we
started and there's a new underground
film people today and they say you sold
out you made independent films which
really makes me laugh
what when I started know people say what
should young people to put in movies
well sex and violence is what they
should put in what everybody should have
in their movies you you just have to
think of a new way to have sex and
violence to get on my generations nerves
I made my first movie hag in a black
leather jacket it cost $60 and
I only showed it once in a beatnik
coffee house and we passed the Hat and
we got 40 but with video and far in one
day I hope to break even
put something from the headlines in your
movie I made my first feature was called
eat your makeup and it was about a
deranged governess and her lover who
kidnapped fashion models and forced them
to eat their makeup and model themselves
to death it sounds a lot better than it
is but there was one great scene and it
were divine played Jackie Kennedy and we
had the complete Kennedy assassination
but it was only a year after it happened
and people really didn't think it was
funny
[Applause]
divides mother didn't even know he was
divine yet and she found the like bloody
Jackie Kennedy outfit wadded up in the
trunk of her car and said what's this
and he was so nervous he just said I am
Jackie Kennedy now I'm the only director
that wishes somebody would colorize his
early movies
[Applause]
mondo trash Oh in a puke-green without a
certain cachet to it I think you know
you're right we didn't ever have like
location managers or anything
we even got busted making that movie
there was a scene where divine is
supposed to be in a convertible and
season nude hitchhiker well I just went
to Hopkins University and filmed and
they called the police and we all
escaped but we got busted the next day
even Ming cup busted in the bathroom at
her house in the bathtub and she had a
great quip for the press she said there
was more exposure in the arrest and the
incident but the shocking thing was
Devine escaped in a gold LeMay toreador
outfit in a 59 Cadillac Eldorado with a
top down in the nude man in the car
which doesn't say a lot for the
Baltimore Police we also never asked
permission and multiple maniacs at the
end when de Brian calls through the
pigshit
we just drove around town I saw a farm
and said do that and Devine jumped out
started crawling around and the pig
started [ __ ] I'm not making this up
imagine how much I would have had to pay
an animal Wrangler you know
[Applause]
pink flamingos is the most notorious
thing I ever did certainly you know but
we didn't then we didn't have those
mixing craft services if you were hungry
you went in the woods hunted something
killed it cooked it made it no special
effects you saw the end that was actor
generated we didn't have prop masters as
a scene is kind of embarrassing to say a
dinner but we're divine opens a turd
someone has gift-wrapped and I said to
him the night before [ __ ] in a box and
bring and he said okay you know now
to hell with prop masters
now would even the most risk-taking
actors today do that would Sean Penn
[ __ ] in a box I don't know you know you
know with with female trouble I just had
divine play a couple roles and that's a
good tip if you don't have a lot of
money have one actor play every part I
don't know what the Screen Actors Guild
would say about that but also caused
controversy desperate living living my
lesbian melodrama in the beginning
lesbians stopped that film from being
shown anywhere they said how could a man
make a comedy about a lesbians but today
lesbians are the first group to bring it
to every college so even minorities they
change what's politically correct if you
wait long enough bad reviews can inspire
you one time I read a review they said
if you see the name John Waters on a
marquee walk on the other side of the
street and hold your nose
I thought well you know so I made
polyester a movie that really did stink
hairspray was accidentally a family
movie I remember when I got a PG rating
I wanted to kill myself you know I
didn't have bad experiences at the
studio at all I made a crybaby with
Johnny Depp and Tracy Lawrence who's
with me here today and the only thing I
learned was how to pitch you know my my
worst pitching experience is I gave a
whole pitch and then the executive
looked at me and said John if I didn't
know you I would think you were insane
and I thought you don't know me so I
guess that's a no you know
the best one was I left the office after
pitching with my producer John Fiedler
we got to the elevator and the executive
ran out and said at the elevator the
answer is yes don't [ __ ] with us don't
go anywhere else I said if they really
say stuff like that here it's amazing
you know the big difference with studios
and independence is where they take you
to test your movies independence usually
take you to a neighborhood that might
like it
where studio has always seemed to take
me to a neighborhood I think my god
where am I is this where Rodney King's
jurors lived also in New York I remember
once they said we're going to the
largest shopping center in New Jersey I
thought oh great just where I'm gonna
knock them dead
you know also with cereal mom I had a
great experience you know with Kathleen
Turner um the one thing you learn if you
work for the studio is you get so much
free food wherever you go that's the one
thing it's a life of free food with
cry-baby you know we had juvenile
delinquents that it was we were praising
in that and I think we need new juvenile
delinquent directors really you've heard
of dogma 95 well I want Dogma John
Waters which would be five rules number
one you have to make an nc-17 movie
without any sex or violence to a
soundtrack of song so atrocious but no
record company in America would release
it three gay movies are everywhere and
that's good but it seems so healthy now
I I kind of like to reverse it you know
I go to colleges all the time and
everyone's gay I can't believe it you
know and I see they aren't and I have to
say sunny you're not gay you're gonna
have to come in you know
and I think we have to reverse the trend
and the 30s gay people always kill
themselves at the end of movies now we
should make movies about heterosexuals
who killed himself because they're not
gay at the end number 4 rule make your
DP take off his glasses or really hire a
blind one because that would have a
whole new kind of art enos I think and
number five don't always just try to
talk a list actresses and making the
movie for scale hire actresses that
haven't worked for ten years or even
better once I tried to hire an actress
who will remain nameless and SAG came
back and said they're a must not hire
I thought must not hire I never heard of
that you know so I wanted all cast of
must not hire
imagine the rap party
I'd love to come to LA you know it
always makes me laugh and are in a great
way you know this is fashion anarchy
here believe me
fringe is abused so heavily and I I like
all the faceless everyone's to look
surprised all the time you know
[Applause]
the really extreme ones looks like
Picasso Prince so you don't even have to
go to art galleries really you know
there's a lot of movies I'd like to
pitch that I know they'll never let me
make so I know everybody here can
greenlight a movie so I'm going to give
you just a few of them one I'd love to
make a nudist camp movie to me happy
healthy idiots on pogo sticks with
airbrush crotches are really sexy but
I'd like to show what people you'd never
want to see nude you know like Ed
McMahon maybe or you know Cicely Tyson I
don't know I you know I wouldn't want to
make a porno movie except they are the
only real outlaw cinema left and the
titles are great I mean shaving Ryan's
privates it's really a good way
my hobby is extreme Catholic behavior
before the Reformation and there's
there's a great book called holy
anorexia the eating disorders of the
saints and I'd really like to bring this
to film you know there's st. Teresa for
some reason always ate scabs and offered
it up to God and I really miss Jane
Fonda and I think this is her comeback
role really
when David Lynch had Twin Peaks and it
was a big head all the big said get the
other nuts you know so I got a lot of
calls saying do you have anything you'd
like to do for TB and I thought it would
be good you know Liberace's boyfriend
wrote this book called behind the
candelabra it should have been beneath I
think but in this book he talked about
how Liberace forced him to have plastic
surgery to look just like Liberace well
what does he expect lying around the
pool all day you got to do something but
the part of his life that I wanted to
bring to a miniseries was later he
became a cocaine addict and was the
lookout in a white guy's in an all-black
burglary ring and then snitched on them
imagine being in prison known as a
snitch for an all-black gang and
Liberace's boyfriend I mean that's lower
than short-eyes eye I'd also like to
help people there's a book out that
comes out every year called toys that
kill and I collect them it's the most
unsafe toys you can buy for your child
every year and I'd like to bring them to
life in animation you know like the Care
Bear Massacre or
I just member Rainbow Brite my new film
that I think is actually we've got a
good good thing on it's called Cecil B
demented it's about a lunatic film
director and his band of film cultists
who kidnap an a-list Hollywood movie
star and force her to be in their
underground movie the thing is it was
really an easy pitch in Europe because
it's very cinematically correct but here
you know they it's about terrorism
against the movie business they I mean
they actually go to producers homes and
punish them for making bad movies so it
was weird when I was pitching it you
could see some of the executives
thinking are they gonna do this to me
you know it was quite difficult I'd like
to close on kind of a spiritual note
[Applause]
dumb knots is really a holy man in my
life
some days I pretend I'm him all day long
you might think you have met me but you
haven't you met Don Knotts that day and
I know one day they're gonna make the
movie of him his life and both Steve
Buscemi and I have discussed this that
we are going to fight to the end to get
the part
so just remember how good it would look
on the side of buses everywhere John
Waters is Don Knotts thank you very much
that wasn't too painful was it it's not
always easy as many of you know I can't
wait to make a movie with that man I
don't I don't know I'm fiending now I
don't want to be underground I don't
want to make it dependent I want to go
underground deeper below joking I'm
hustling him in the back y'all just
don't know but I already bribed him to
be in his movie I'm paying him to be in
his next movie okay now we're gonna move
on to the Best Supporting female
category
you may remember one of our presenters
from the John Waters film cry-baby
in which he played a role called hateful
guard his co-presenter is last year's
Spirit Award winner in this very
category for her role and ease by you
please share your love with Willem Dafoe
and Debby Morgan
[Applause]
[Music]
I just want to say that I'm celebrating
two anniversaries today my second
wedding anniversary happy Anniversary
honey
and the second anniversary of being part
of the Spirit Awards winning this award
last year for Best Supporting Actress
was I don't know such an orgasmic
experience for me do you agree with that
honey
I say that because it was the climax is
such an incredible year for me and I'm
sure that the five women who were
nominated in this category tonight
share that same sentiment and our
nominees for Best Supporting female are
stark enchanting for the baby dance
Patricia Clarkson for high arc
Lisa Kudrow for the opposite of sex
Lynn Redgrave for gods and monsters
and Joe Lee Richardson for under heaven
and the spirit award goes to Lynn
Redgrave Oh men always pulling legs
everything is comedy are very amusing
home obviously bro
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
well you probably do if you've been
reading the tabloids how much this means
to me right now I'm so proud to be here
first as a nominee with my extraordinary
leading man Ian McKellen and Brendan
Fraser at our table my special thanks to
director screenwriter who truly put his
independent spirit on the screen Bill
Condon thank you so much to Regent films
and to Lionsgate and anybody who put
money into it Jerry off say hey thanks
BBC films all those people but look
here's the thing
I began him in independent films a
hundred and forty years ago with I've
had such a long career even I can't
remember it but it was with with Tony
Richardson's woodfall films I was in Tom
Jones and in the girl with green eyes
Thank You coke and twister Tony and then
I had a long time in Siberia the worst
moment was when I was told by my then
agent that I was on the B list for
Shelley Duvall's Faerie Tale theatre or
whatever it was called Shelley darling
you know remember
and then I have an in a Renaissance and
my new life in film has been thanks to
independent films thanks to Scott Hicks
finding me in Houston Texas for shine
and there now with with Bill and and
gods and monsters and I would just like
to say that I'm a woman of a certain age
and this independence happens at a
moment when I am striking out in a new
and independent life and there are three
women who have helped me stand here
without crying in front of all of you
and they are my shrink my lawyer and my
new agent so Martha Emily and Susan
Smith god bless you
next up is the true within fiction award
for Best Documentary and here to present
it as a man whose life really is true
within fiction please hold on to your
seats and welcome a kindred independent
spirit the governor of Minnesota Jesse
Ventura
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
imagine I'm the guy here that has armed
bodyguards it's alright you didn't laugh
unlike the fiction filmmaker who usually
knows how his or her movie is going to
turn out a documentary filmmaker embarks
on an odyssey of much greater risk the
documentary filmmaker often must proceed
not with a map of where he or she is
going but simply with faith what the
journey will be worth that the journey
will be worth the trouble of course
faith is good but faith plus money is
better and to that end one emerging
documentary filmmaker here is about to
receive $20,000 this unrestricted grant
is funded by the independent film
channel and Landmark Theaters and is
presented and is presented to the
director of a documentary film of
outstanding artistic quality the
finalists for the third annual truer
than fiction award are not interesting
I'm giving this away Vicky Funari for
Paulina
Tim Kirkman for deer Jessi Julia lock
dev for moments of impact
Barbara sonim born for regret to inform
and Kyra Thompson for dying to tell the
story the recipient of the truth and
fiction award is Barbara Sun and born
for regret to inform
[Applause]
or actually touch my life the bomb were
dropping in my house why are they
burning down my house
my neighbor house everything from that
on nothing it black or white it's all
great just like the smoke
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
I'm really very moved to receive this
award I want to thank the IFP the
independent film channel and Landmark
Theaters for making it possible this has
been a ten and a half year journey
actually two from the beginning of the
film until getting it done and actually
11 years since I started it it's the
documentary about the long-term effects
of war from the point of view of women
and I interviewed Vietnam war widows
from both sides of the conflict and it
chronicles my own journey my first
husband died in the war in 1968 it
chronicles my own journey back to
Vietnam and I weave the stories of
Vietnam war widows through that journey
and we really get to see what happens in
a country where the war takes place I
want to thank the many people who helped
me I know everyone says that
documentaries are a collaborative
process that all films are a
collaborative process but documentaries
are made in the editing room the other
producer on the project Janet call the
film's editors Lucy Massey Phoenix and
Ken Schneider the woman who accompanied
me and who is the principal character in
the film who's here with me today so on
yeah Kevin's and my co-producer who is
also my husband I never could have done
it without him thank you very much
well everyone we have officially reached
the hump the midway point of the show
this show lasted a week it will be
Wednesday
but that was a year it would be June if
it was the Oscars you'd be sleeping
through another commercial break I'm
just kidding they wrote that for me
don't hold it against me God you guys
need to loosen up or something oh is it
all that free room eating wine you
getting at their tables what's going on
now we move on to the Best
Cinematography and best foreign film
presenting the awards our Lara friend
Flynn Boyle and Mike my homeboy
Rappaport
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
first of all why don't we give a hold of
applause to Queen Latifah beautiful
beautiful holy
okay the nominees for Best
Cinematography are Maurice Albert II for
velvet goldmine
Matthew Lee batik for pi Tami Riker for
hi art
Paul surah c4 affliction
and Malik Sahid for belly and the spirit
award goes to
maurice albertine for velvet go live
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
this is fantastic
Maurice unfortunately could not be here
she's shooting a film in New York with
Stanley Tucci but she is an amazing
woman and an amazing director of
photography and this was an incredibly
challenging project for all of us and
the incredible beauty that you brought
to the film I think speaks for itself so
this is for Maurice thank you so much
it's Michael's birthday okay thank you
you know they didn't give us a script
and whenever I've been here to watch one
of these I always said if I was there I
wouldn't use a script and now they
didn't give us a script take up time
yeah we're scared to death okay next up
is best foreign film and they brought us
to do best foreign film because of our
reputable grasp of the English language
okay
the nominees are the celebration
directed by Thomas Vinterberg
the eel directed by show he Imam Ora the
general directed by John Boorman
Central Station directed by Walter
Salles
and fireworks directed by Takeshi Kitano
and the spirit award goes to my hands
are shaking
but it goes to the celebration
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh I was just having some rice down
there Thomas Vinterberg couldn't be here
today so I'm here on his behalf
I'm just an humble actor he sends his
best regards this is a great great thing
really I have my son - a warm thank you
to chopper films they do yes they they
did the best job promoting the movie
over here and and to all the people
working around or with October films
thank you and see this now this is a
rare this is an a hip hip hooray for the
independent industry a hip hip hooray
for the infant death yeah
and see I'm just being a farm boy from
from Copenhagen and this is a rare
opportunity for me to say something
besides all this as I saw Lisa could Rob
here and I just want to say to you
because you're a genius
well thank you and I'll pass this on to
Thomas Vinterberg he truly deserves this
and thank you Independent Spirit Award
thank you
[Applause]
hi hey Bubba ray I'm having a good time
back here now it is my pleasure to
introduce a woman who's been involved
with independent movies since they had
titles like beach blanket bingo since
our early days with Sam Arkoff and Roger
Corman she's been associated with such
films as the tin drum Breaker Morant
Cinema Paradiso and Wes Anderson's debut
film bottle rocky please welcome the
president of the IFP West Barbara Boyle
[Music]
[Applause]
so if anyone doubts it God is definitely
looking down at the independence today
beautiful sunny day congratulations to
everyone in this room for an incredible
year of independent film I have to of
course give you the family report my
granddaughters now three Lily Boyle and
Lily Weinstein with the backing of Barry
Diller are buying everything that
bargain Harvey don't own Jake my
grandson has been also talking to Lily
Weinstein but she said he's one but she
said before they go any further he has
to agree to change his name to Weinstein
and the other really important news is
our executive director and our CEO
Michael Harrison and Don Hudson have
welcomed their first son Samuel
so much has talked about independence
and for those who know me you know I'm a
big baseball fan and I actually don't
believe where the minor leagues waiting
to become major leagues
I believe we are the major leagues and I
think that the thing that has happened
really is that the other league has
pulled more and more from our league and
that's the way it should be the final
thing I have to say is I had a wonderful
wonderful week because I had Ian
McKellen at my house and I am in love
there are a lot of other people there
too 300 of them but he's the only one I
can remember and now it's my pleasure to
introduce two actors who were both in
films this year at Sundance at the Film
Festival she's an actress with a long
history of work and independent feel
film and will next be seen in happy
Texas those are really happy people and
he will appear in the upcoming thick as
thieves presenting the award for the
best male actor our Illeana Douglas and
Alex gorgeous Baldwin
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
gorgeous though we don't have time
sadly at the ceremony to honor all of
the technicians and other artists in the
independent cinema so the spirit Awards
held a separate luncheon this past
Wednesday the luncheon was held in the
banquet room of Sam's Hofbrau which sits
in the shadow of some of the finest
hotels in downtown Los Angeles the
ceremony was hosted by head waiter Lyle
Paige and despite a failure of the air
conditioning system almost a dozen
nominees stuck around to honor their
fellow colleagues here are the
highlights of the awards given out at
this previous ceremony the clapper
loader is indispensable to any film
punctuality attention to detail and of
course a firm grip are hallmarks of this
really under celebrated crew position
accepting the award for lifetime
achievement as the clapper loader was
Stuart Larsen mr. Larsen has worked as a
clapper loader on over 125 independent
films since 1975 he has never once been
paid
[Laughter]
also presented wednesday afternoon was
the TRW award for best achievement in
credit card debt
this year's winner Blair Davis
it always wanted to make an independent
film called my friends sit in a coffee
house and talk lacking the requisite
financial resources miss Davis raise
production funds by securing nine visa
cards seven master cards and three
American Express gold cards
sadly production was halted after one
week when miss Davis was arrested by US
Marshals on ten counts of fraud she is
currently incarcerated at the Sybil
brand Institute accepting the award on
behalf of Miss Davis was and finally a
really special award was presented this
year and it was called the shelf this
award was presented to Miramax Films in
recognition of the most films acquired
for distribution but never actually
released
that is so great because they just
bought my new movie so I guess that
means I'll be on the show anyway
accepting on behalf of Bob and and
Harvey because they were unavailable
they were like pressing gwennie's dress
for tomorrow
[Applause]
wild pants head winner
[Applause]
many other film professionals were
honored at the ceremony and the clapper
loader Stewart Larson probably put it
best when he remarked I think a good
time was had by all and at least you can
say no Lifetime Achievement Award for
Elia Kazan alright and now we get to our
real purpose here Alec I think you are
so great
and this is divorced from that this is
just a cheap piece of tin really oh I'm
so sorry
our real reason that we're here is to
present the award for the best male lead
and the nominees are Dylan Baker for
happy
ian mckellen four gods and monsters
the astonishing mr. Nick Nolte for a
picture
Sean Penn for hurly-burly
and port need advance for blind faith
the spirit award goes to
ian mckellen
you are almost actual there from a
series of clinical then you don't even
think of me that way do you
I know a real man like you would break
my neck if I semesters native finger
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
I've developed a new
thank you well I don't know it's it's
very hard being a foreigner in your
country at this particular time of the
and I've enjoyed every single minute of
it and I never want to go through it
again but this has really helped to make
this week worthwhile whatever else
happens in the future
I play James Whale in gods and monsters
James well worked for studio of course
but in the days when Studios felt more
like independent filmmakers and it was
only when the Laemmle brothers stopped
running a family business and sold out
to New York bankers that James Whale got
disaffected with the movies so I guess
his spirit is with us here today he says
in the movie that making making movies
is the most wonderful thing in the world
working with friends and entertaining
people and that's about it and the
friends who were involved with gods and
monsters long before I ever got there
were Bill Condon of course with his
wonderful screenplay from Christopher
Browns novel
our producers Cloud Barca Gregg Fienberg
and from region pork college from Mark
Harris and now have the support of
Lionsgate some flash points throughout
the world we're going ahead and we made
this little move it just for love not
for money not for glory and it turns
other people actually like it I've only
made one rule in my professional life
and that is only to do a play or a film
that I would want to see myself and to
work with the best possible people and
that happened in this case my dear
darling Lynn and my dear darling Brendan
Fraser who's here today and I had the
best time in the world and I suppose the
part is a good one because it tells the
truth it tells the truth about what it's
like to be a filmmaker and how often is
Hollywood done that and it tells the
truth of what it was like to be but that
particular gay man James Whale in that
particular time in your history whether
things are changing I don't know but
here's an openly gay man very happy to
say good morning and thank you
for like the Sandman on the Apollo I got
to keep chasing those guys on the other
side but it's fun and stuff the next
award is for best female lead one of our
presenters was in after-hours the first
film ever to receive a Spirit Award for
Best Feature and with her is an actor
who recently won a Golden Globe for his
portrayal of Sammy Davis jr. in the Rat
Pack please welcome Rosanna Arquette and
Don Cheadle
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so happy to be here presenting today I
love independent films characters I get
to play absolutely
oh the ideas they get they put out there
and the idea is definitely being outside
of the mainstream oh yeah outside
outside and I know you know what I mean
but the reward of getting to work for
less than scary a lot less a lot less
[Applause]
the nominees for best female lead are
Katrine cartilage for claire Dolan
with Peter Ricci for the opposite of sex
Ally Sheedy for high art
Robin Tunney for Niagara Niagara
and alfre woodard for down in the Delta
the spirit award goes to
[Applause]
it's got more line between me and work
and people were glomming on to something
I was doing then and it just got trapped
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
I'm sorry but you have no idea how long
mr. this road has been a very very long
road and I told Rosana who is one of my
very best friends and I was knowing me
for about good over the years that she
was gonna have to lie
because I would do it for her but it
really said that nobody made a mistake
oh my god oh my god you don't know I'm
standing here next to Roseann
you have no idea none none none none and
Nick you know there are a few people
here who really know Erik Heather
sorry everybody's been really quick I'm
not gonna be quick
[Laughter]
I've never been nominated for anything
before this may never happen again I'm
taking my [ __ ] time
[Applause]
you have no idea how much the two of us
have been through at least 12 years of
not being able to get an audition for a
sitcom right well I will admit it
Roseanna is a lot more tasteful about
these things than I am
but that is the truth this movie is an
absolute sending from God leaves I
didn't thank you
[ __ ] my friend see my friend who is
happy for me I'm so happy for her she
deserves it she's a great actor and you
deserve my god you know you know no I
want you to stay here with me
we are interchangeable and that's the
way it is Lisa where are you Lisa great
director Lisa thank you Lisa for writing
a screenplay that was a beautiful
beautiful screenplay a screenplay that
no one changed one word of it was
perfect and not only that but you took a
chance on me you have a chance on me
when I couldn't get arrested for
anything do you know what I mean there
is no way that I can express my
gratitude to you for that because I'm an
actor and someone's got to take a chance
on me you know thank you so much for
writing that screenplay and directing it
so beautifully and giving me that
character that I got to fly with yes and
letting me fly with it right there stay
here
[Applause]
okay this is Oscar Rosanna's award you
don't know that but she does Lisa um
Tammy Riker beautiful cinematography let
me do this movie with no makeup exactly
as I am just shot the thing from the
get-go no worry about it nobody on this
movie was worried that it was about
lesbians addicted to heroin who are like
dropping out from photography and
sitting in a loft nobody worried about
it and I'm not supposed to say this but
I'm gonna say it this movie was shot for
less than half a million dollars yes
this movie for nothing everybody who
worked on this movie worked for nothing
nothing
modified scale low-budget if you're an
actor you know exactly what that means
Dolly's Jeff who financed this movie out
of his pocket as I happen to know Jeanne
Susan Stover Laurie my friends who did
it
Patti Clarkson yeah
turned in an unbelievable performance
performance I'm so nervous I'm like the
unbelievable Tammy Grimes David Thornton
art this is our cast who worked for
nothing
bill sage and Wong Radha Mitchell where
are you my girlfriends
where are you Radha Radha
we're come on right here in awe see I
know you'll stand up thank you
Radha Mitchell my mom who let me use her
life in this movie and was not worried
about it
October films
and I have to say this I know there are
a lot of you at October films that had a
lot to do with this movie but there's
one guy at October films who is my guy
who called me all the time who showed up
at every single thing who called me when
things didn't work out when they did
work out who is my champion and he is
the person I want to thank for his great
taste and his great courage in
supporting independent film including
Tony bouys movie which is going to come
out and a lot of other films like the
celebration Bingham ray
the only trustworthy person I have ever
met in excellent years of working Denis
rights for getting me through it
Jojo Weldon for the photography which
was not my photography
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
we're - Roxanna go okay fine
it's okay I can deal oh I'm gonna keep
this Ian McKellan left his I'm gonna
keep this alright that's the V major
people I need to thank aside from those
people there are a few people here I
can't do this any other way this is
corny as hell please bear with me but I
may never ever be in this position again
and I really want to do this good the
following people please stand up
Tim angle Rachel she D get up
redraws belt
where are you thank you David Lansbury
my husband get up I don't care that they
want me off I'm not done yet
Nancy wilkinson get up stand up come on
please they want me off I'm gonna finish
David stand up please stand up please
stand up David God's sake never listen
to me
kneel Konigsberg
and Harold Gus Kahn is here in my spirit
who is my teacher who changed the way I
work for the past 10 years and who has
really really taught me thank you for
teaching me everything thank you for
standing by me thank you for taking me
in when nobody else would take me in
thank you to kneel for standing by me
for 12 years or however long you want to
say it is when nobody wanted to hire me
for really believing in me and for
standing behind me and believing that I
was something more than just the
Breakfast Club
I really love you Neal and I really
really honor you this is your award
thank you
oh that was great I had enough time to
smoke a cigarette and drink a beer and
talk [ __ ] in the back and get a free
movado watch and then I'm back so what
happened while I was going yes I love
that they would have having a [ __ ] fit
if this was the act
oscar's you know that they got a [ __ ]
pit in the back I'm not gonna lie but it
was funny to me so uh you know what do I
care I'm happy for her I love her all
right we about to give out yet another
20 grand
now tell me another word shoulder does
that here to present the Movado someone
to watch award our Jeff Goldblum and
Gina Gershon
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
every year since 1995 the IFP West has
given the someone to watch award to a
talented filmmaker of singular vision
who hasn't received appropriate
recognition past winners have included
Christopher Muench Larry Fessenden Scott
Saunders the first winner of this award
lodged Carrigan has proved he was indeed
someone to watch as his most recent film
Clair Dolan is nominated this year for
Best Director and Best Feature this
award comes with a grant of $20,000 Wow
yeah $20,000 funded by movado watch
listen the grant is unrestricted which
means that the winner may spend the
money in any way to help finance another
movie or to take a year off to write a
script or to pay off the debt that the
winner probably incurred making his or
her last film
Bali's nice could they do anything they
want go do anything they want with it
that's right that's pretty good okay
sorry the finalists for the fifth annual
someone to watch award are Tony Barbieri
director of one simple economics you get
signed for nothing they got nothing
invested in man so when they start
dropping guys gets the first to go the
guys are giving nothing to that's right
I'm not gonna be one of those guys Lin
Hershman Leeson director of conceiving a
de Lucas this is just a simulation
[Music]
Eric treta director of snow things have
been bad for a long time ever since we
moved in together I did once now we have
a deal
this year's winner of the Movado someone
to watch award used non-professional
actors hmm and worked without a formal
script to create a humorous and
heartfelt film that blends narrative and
documentary styles the film titled 13
bottles an adolescent girl as she
searches for family love and a car of
her own here's a clip from 13 Thomas do
you like this Clark yes I do
it has a pitch of Christ and when you're
chilled a little bit you see it's the
pitch of the law Last Supper and I
really like I want you to have this
clock well thank you welcome what the
hell is this cheesy piece of crap right
here it reminds me of somebody putting
Jesus on black velvet and hanging it up
on their wall they just saw I've seen
Jesus don't like a overhang you like I
like it
hmm so now please welcome the director
of 13 and the winner of the 1999 Movado
someone to watch award David Williams
[Applause]
[Music]
when I get back to Richmond I'm going to
tell people I was in LA for three days
and I was walking down the beach and
someone gave me $20,000 when I first
heard about the award I thought this
would be the start of my next film and
then a thought okay that's amore and
realized it probably is the whole budget
for my next film
I want to thank IFP West and Lovato for
the award and especially the two
wonderful actors in my film
Nina Dickens and Lillian Foley my film
crew marked Chang and Bernice Baker the
film lay out Commonwealth films and I
was told to make sure I mentioned the
the musicians that did the music for the
film so chef Williams and Carlos Garza
and Cecil Hooker thank you
[Applause]
you would think after watching everybody
want that okay be a trendsetter
welcome to the homestretch only two more
awards to go presenting the Spirit Award
for Best Director our two performers who
have been honored throughout their
careers she won a Spirit Award for her
performance and Sex Lies and videotape
and he is nominated for an Academy Award
for his performance in Shakespeare in
Love and had the best makeup here are
geoffrey rush and Andie MacDowell
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
the nominees for best director Wes
Anderson for Rushmore
Todd Haynes for velvet goldmine
Lodge Carrigan for Clare Dolan Paul
Schrader for affliction
and Todd salons for happiness
and the spirit award goes to Wes
Anderson for a small
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I asked bill to write one for me too he
said this is all the director like me
can ever hope to get tonight is the peak
of my entire life
and tomorrow I will be on the shoot-down
and he added I also wouldn't be here if
it weren't for Bill Murray but I guess
everyone knows that and I also want to
thank the rest of our cast Jason
Schwartzman and
Olivia Williams and Seymour Cassell
Brian Cox and our producers Barry Mendel
and Paul ship and also the people a
touchstone who helped us get the movie
done the way we wanted to do it and and
Jim Brooks and especially my co-writer
Owen Wilson who's my closest
collaborator thank you very much
okay that's just about it
only one more Spirit Award left this
award has been won in the past by such
movies as platoon Sex Lies and videotape
Pulp Fiction and last year by the
Apostle hey I'm keeping this I like that
guy in a few moments a new film will be
added to that list so let's all take a
deep breath
okay let it out here to present the
Award for Best Feature welcome
Minnie Driver and Brendan Fraser
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
nominees for best feature our affliction
produced by the inter Iseman I became
real careful around huh it was careful
child I became a careful adult but at
least I was never afflicted by that
man's violence claire doan produced by
Andrew watt and Marin comments what are
you gonna do when you start falling
apart you should be on the street for
twenty bucks a pop you're not a no girl
you should know better than to let them
get inside you stretch you oh god sea
monsters produced by Paul Kotchman Gregg
Fienberg and Mark are Harris to be
married mr. whale what one can live as
husband and wife without getting the law
involved did so then you did have a wife
or a husband depending on which of us
who asked the velvet goldmine produced
by Christian Vachon yeah doctor you to
change Brian Slade pop singer in a
Maxwell demon space age in super star
because the secret of becoming a star is
knowing how to behave like one and a
soldier's daughter never cries produced
by his male merchant come on now you
know a soldier's daughter the soldier's
daughter again anyway I'm not I'm the
writers daughter
in the spirit award
goes to will you be my witness many gods
and monsters
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Wow
I'm Greg Paul college Minh Mark Harris
and Bill Condon I have nothing prepared
because we've we've been to a few of
these in the last couple of months it's
a very surreal situation and every time
you know if Stephen Spielberg was in the
room and we never got up here so I was
happy not to see him here today even
though I love the man so this is really
something because you're our family this
is where we I think believe we really
belonged and this is just um
it's it's amazing so thank you very much
the IFP first and foremost for having
this ceremony for all of us and for
honoring us here today and for all of
you I didn't shake this much since the
time Ian McKellen's agent said that he
was going to do the movie yeah a lot of
people to thank
I'll be just a little longer than Allie
but now I can speak quickly but this
this movie started with something that I
find very important in our business and
that is a what I call a singular vision
and it was the vision of Bill Condon who
who just front from the beginning knew
the movie he wanted to make and and
never wavered from it and mark and Paul
never asked us to waver from it and we
never did and and it's just I can't say
enough about working with Bill Condon in
terms of the many people to thank and
I'll do this as quickly as possible but
they're important the gentleman at
flashpoint David and Beau thank you very
much for your support there was a time
where this movie may not have made it to
the screen and they really helped aside
from financing the movie continuing to
finance the movie to make sure it
happened and that is the true true
independent spirit and you know we all
hope for that and we got it on this one
so thank you - you're gonna have to help
me if I leave people out but obviously -
to the people at Showtime Jerry Matt
Sharon and everybody else who also
helped get this movie going we really
appreciate everything you've done for us
Clive Barker who came on board early on
and was a godfather for us and first of
all
Ian and Lynn if you're in the audience
of you thank you very much that's that
you know it's the first people in my
mind I'm thinking you know yes
go ahead thank you Marcus I've never
done this before and I hope to do it
again tomorrow night
anyway I I was I was gonna I was gonna
leave after I was so like anxious for
Ian and Lynn to win that after Ian got
the award I was ready to go and I forgot
we were up for this so this is like an
amazing thing
I want to thank God that's really what
it's all about
[Music]
life is good all the time no matter
what's going on and it's been a great
joy and a pleasure to be associated with
a film that has a purpose and a meaning
that has a spiritual theme to it that
says something to people that I think
well I think the recognition from what
we've got so far was just received very
well and it's just an honor to be
associated with my partner Paul and the
cast we have and it's just incredible so
thank you very much
[Music]
we also have to thank our partner Steve
Jacko who's been with us behind us and
here every step of the way
Steve big round of applause for you we
have to thank our friends at lions gates
for making sure that all you wonderful
people got to see this movie and we
absolutely have to thank Brendon and Ian
and Lynn because without your magic this
movie would just be celluloid thank you
Chris Brown will wrote father of
Frankenstein he's hit where it all
started thank you
thank you very much
fabulous you know I told those guys if
they wanted pictures they had to take
off one article of clothing for each
shot oh well alright y'all that's it
we've given out 15 Independent Spirit
Awards you made 15 people real happy and
a couple of people a lot riches we going
through a ton of pasta and a couple
dozen bottles of rum and that's just for
me a Randy Quaid before we leave I'd
just like to mention that I'm the first
woman to host this show I guess if
you're gonna get a woman
[Applause]
[Music]